welcome to the huberman lab podcast
where we discuss science
and science-based tools for everyday
life
i'm andrew hueberman and i'm a professor
of neurobiology and
ophthalmology at stanford school of
medicine today we're going to talk
all about hearing and balance and how
you can use your ability to hear
specific things
and your balance system in order to
learn anything faster
the auditory system meaning the hearing
system and your balance system which is
called the vestibular system
interact with all the other systems of
the brain and body
and used properly can allow you to learn
information more quickly
remember that information longer and
with more
ease and you can also improve the way
you can hear you can improve
your balance we're going to talk about
tools for all of that
this is one area of science where we
understand a lot about the cells and the
mechanisms in the ear and in the brain
and so forth
so we're going to talk about that a
little bit and then we're going to get
directly into protocols
meaning tools we're also going to talk
about
ways in which the auditory imbalance
system suffer we're going to talk about
tinnitus which is this
ringing of the years that unfortunately
for people that suffer from it
they really suffer it's very intrusive
for them we're going to talk about some
treatments that can work
in some circumstances and some of the
more recent emerging treatments
that i think many people aren't aware of
we're also going to talk about this
what seems like kind of a weird fact
which is that 70 percent of people
all people make what are called auto
acoustic emissions
their ears actually make noises chances
are you your ears are making noises
right now
but you can't perceive them and yet
those can have an influence on other
people
and animals in your environment it's a
fascinating aspect to your biology
you're going to learn a lot about how
your biology and brain and ears
and the so-called inner ear that's
associated with balance you're going to
learn a lot about how all those work
you're going to learn a lot of
neuroscience
i'll even tell you what type of music to
listen to and if you listen to me
you can leverage that in order to learn
faster before we begin talking about the
science of hearing and balance
and tools that leverage hearing
imbalance for learning faster
i want to provide some information about
another way to learn
much faster there's a paper that was
published recently
this is a paper that was published in
cell reports an
excellent journal it's a peer-reviewed
paper
from a really excellent group looking at
skill learning now previously
i've talked about how in the attempt to
learn skills
the vital thing to do is to get
lots of repetitions you've heard of the
10 000 hours thing you've heard of
you know lots of different strategies
for learning faster 80 20 rule and all
that
the bottom line is you need to generate
many many repetitions
of something that you're trying to learn
and the errors that you generate are
also very important for learning
it also turns out that taking rest
within the learning episode is very
important i want to be really clear what
i'm referring to here
in earlier episodes i've discussed how
when you're trying to learn something
it's beneficial it's been shown in
scientific studies
that if you take a 20-minute shallow nap
or you simply do nothing after a period
of learning that it enhances the rates
of learning
and the depth of learning your ability
to learn and remember that information
what i'm about to describe are new data
that say that you actually should be
should be injecting rest within the
learning episode
i'm not talking about going to sleep
while learning
this is the way that the study was done
the study
involved having people learn sequences
of numbers or keys on a piano
so let's use the keys on a piano example
i'm not a musician
but i think i'll get this correct
they asked people to practice a sequence
of keys
g d f e g g d
f e g g d f e g and they would practice
that either continually for a given
amount of time
or they would just do that for 10
seconds they would play
g d f e g g d f e g g d f e g g d f e g
for 10 seconds and then they would take
a 10 second
pause a rest it would just space
take a space or a period of time but
they do nothing for 10 seconds
then they would go back to g d f e g g d
f e g
so the two conditions essentially
were to have people practice continually
lots of repetitions
or to inject or insert these periods of
of 10 seconds idle time where they're
not doing anything they're not looking
at their phone
they're not focusing on anything they're
just letting their mind drift wherever
it wants to go
and they are not touching the keys on
the keyboard
what they found was that the rates of
learning
the skill acquisition and the retention
of the skills was significantly faster
when they injected these
short periods of rest these 10-second
rest periods
and the the rates of learning were
when i say significantly faster were
much much faster i'll reveal what that
was in just a moment
but you might ask why would this work
why would it be that injecting these 10
second rest periods would enhance
rates of learning what they called them
was micro offline gains because they're
sort of taking their brain offline
from the learning task for a moment well
it turns out the brain isn't going
offline at all
you've probably heard of the hippocampus
the area of the brain involved in memory
and the neocortex the area of the brain
that's involved in processing sensory
information
well it turns out that during these
brief periods of rest these 10 second
rest periods
the hippocampus and the cortex are
active in ways such that you get a
20 times repeat of
the gd feg it's a temporal compression
as they say so
basically the rehearsal continues while
you rest
but at 20 times the speed so if you were
normally getting just
let's just say five repetitions of gdf
eg
gdfeg gdfeg per 10 seconds now you
multiply that times 20 in the rest
periods you've practiced it 100 times
your brain has practiced it we know this
because they were doing brain imaging
functional imaging of these people
with brain scanners while they were
doing this this is an absolutely
staggering effect and it's one that
believe it or not
has been hypothesized or thought to
exist for a very long time
this effect is called the spacing effect
and it was actually
first proposed by ebington in 1885
and since then it's been demonstrated
for a huge number of different what they
call domains in the cognitive domain so
for learning languages
for in the physical domain so for
learning skills that involve a motor
sequence
it's been demonstrated for a huge number
of different
categories of learning if you want to
learn
all about the spacing effect and the
categories of learning that it can
impact
there's a wonderful review article i'll
provide a link to it
the title of the review article is
parallels between spacing effects during
behavioral and cellular learning what
that review really does
is it ties the behavioral learning and
the improvement of skill
to the underlying changes in neurons
that can explain that learning i should
mention that the paper that i'm
referring to
the more recent paper that injects these
10 second
little micro offline games rest periods
is the work of the laboratory of leonard
cohen
not the musician letter and cohen he
passed away he was not a neuroscientist
a wonderful poet a musician but not a
neuroscientist
again the paper was published in cell
reports and we will provide a link to
the full paper
as well so the takeaway is if you're
trying to learn something
you need to get those reps in but one
way that you can get 20 times the number
of reps in
is by injecting these little 10 second
periods of doing nothing
again during those rest periods you
really don't want to attend to anything
else
as much as possible you could close your
eyes if you want or you can just simply
wait
and then get right back into generating
repetitions i find these papers that
sell
reports and other journals have been
publishing recently to be fascinating
because they're really helping us
understand what are the best protocols
for learning
anything and they really uh leverage the
fact that the brain is willing to
generate repetitions for us provide
provided that we give it the rest that
it needs so inject rest throughout the
learning period
and if you can based on the scientific
data you would also want to take a 20
minute
nap or a 20 minute decompress period
where you're not doing anything after a
period of learning
i think those could both synergize in
order to enhance
learning even further although that
hasn't been looked at yet before we
begin
talking about hearing and balance i just
want to mention that this podcast is
separate from my teaching and research
roles at stanford
it is however part of my desire and
effort to bring zero cost to consumer
information about science
and science related tools to the general
public
in keeping with that theme i want to
thank the sponsors of today's podcast
and make it clear that we only work with
sponsors whose products we absolutely
love
and that we think you will benefit from
as well
our first sponsor is roka roka makes
sunglasses and eyeglasses that in my
opinion
are the very highest quality available
the company was founded by two
all-american swimmers from stanford
and everything about their eyeglasses
and sunglasses were
created with performance in mind these
eyeglasses and sunglasses have a number
of features that really make them unique
first of all they're extremely
lightweight
the optical clarity of the lenses is
spectacular
and for the sunglasses they have this
really great feature which is
as you move in and out of shadows or
as across the day the amount of sunshine
might change
you always experience the world as clear
and bright
and that can only come from really
understanding how the visual system
works
the visual system has all these
mechanisms for adaptation and
habituation
you don't need to know how those things
work but the folks at roca clearly do
because you put these glasses on and you
don't even notice that they're on
they also stay on your face even if you
get sweaty they were designed
to be used while active so running and
biking etc
or indoors one thing that i really like
about roka eyeglasses and sunglasses
is that the aesthetic is terrific even
though they were designed for
performance
unlike a lot of sunglasses out there
that were designed for performance that
looked kind of ridiculous kind of space
age
roca eyeglasses and sunglasses you could
wear anywhere
and the aesthetic is really clean and
they have a huge number of different
styles to select from
if you'd like to try roka eyeglasses you
can go to roka that's
roka.com and enter the code huberman to
save 20
off your first order that's roca
roka.com and enter the code huberman at
checkout
today's podcast is also brought to us by
inside tracker
inside tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and dna
to help you better understand your body
and reach your health goals
i've long been a believer in getting
regular blood work done
for the simple reason that many of the
factors that
impact our immediate and long-term
health can only be analyzed from a
quality blood test
and now with the advent of dna tests we
can get further
insight and information into how our
metabolism is working
how our brain is functioning how our
endocrine system
meaning our hormone system is
functioning one of the issues with a lot
of companies and programs that involve
getting blood and dna tests however
is that you get the information back you
don't know what to do with that
information with inside tracker they
make all of that
very easy first of all they can send
someone to your home to take the samples
if you like
or you can go to a local clinic you get
the information back
and of course you get all the numbers
and levels of hormone factors metabolic
factors etc
but the dashboard inside tracker
provides directives so that if you want
to bring those numbers up or bring them
down
or if you want to keep them in the same
range it points to specific regimens
related to
nutrition exercise and other lifestyle
factors so you can really move around
those numbers to best suit your health
goals and health status
if you want to try inside tracker you
can go to insidetracker.com
huberman and you'll get 25 percent off
any of inside tracker's plans just use
the code
huberman at checkout today's podcast is
also brought to us by headspace
headspace is a meditation app that's
backed by 25 published studies
and in addition to those there are
hundreds of studies showing
that meditation is beneficial for our
brain and for our body
one of the challenges however is
maintaining a meditation practice
i started meditating a long time ago but
i found it very hard to keep that
practice going
then i discovered the headspace
meditation app and what i found
was that because they have meditations
that are very short as well as some that
are longer and some that are
much longer i could maintain my
meditation practice sometimes i do a
short five-minute meditation sometimes i
do 20-minute meditation
i try and meditate at least 20 minutes
per day
but sometimes some weeks i only do it
five times a week and i'll just meditate
for longer
so with headspace you have the full
palette of meditations to select from
if you want to try headspace you can go
to headspace.com
special offer and if you do that you'll
get a free one-month trial
so no cost whatsoever with their full
library of meditations that's the best
offer that they have
so again if you want to try headspace
and you want to get access to all their
meditations for free
go to headspace.com special offer
can you hear me can you hear me
okay well if you can hear me that's
amazing because what it means
is that my voice is causing little tiny
changes in the airwaves wherever you
happen to be
and that your ears and whatever is
contained in those ears
and in your brain can take those sound
waves and make sense of them
and that is an absolutely fantastic and
staggering feat of biology and yet we
understand a lot
about how that process works so i'm
going to teach it to you now
in simple terms over the next few
minutes so what we call
ears have a technical name that
technical
technical name is oracles but more often
they're called
pinna the pinas p-i-n-n-a
pinna and the pinnas of your ears
this outer part that is made of
cartilage and stuff
is arranged such that it can capture
sound
in the best way for your head size
we're going to talk about ear size also
because it turns out that your ears
change size across
the lifespan and that how big your ears
are
or rather how fast your ears are
changing size
is a pretty good indication of how fast
you're aging so we'll get to that in a
few minutes but
i want to talk about these things that
we call ears and some of the stuff
contained within them
that allow us to hear so the shape of
these
ears that we have is such that it
amplifies
high frequency sounds high frequency
sounds as the name suggests so that is
the squeakier stuff
right so low frequency sound cost yellow
snoring in the background that's a low
frequency sound
or high frequency sound okay so we have
low frequency sounds and high frequency
sounds and everything in between
now those sound waves get captured by
our ears
and those sound waves for those of you
that don't
maybe fully conceptualize sound waves
are literally
just fluctuations or shifts
in the way that air is moving
toward your ear and through space in the
same way that water can have waves
the air can have waves okay so it's
reverberation of air
those come in through your ears and you
have what's called
your eardrum and on the inside of your
eardrum
there's a little bony thing that's
shaped like a little hammer
so attached to that eardrum which can
move back and forth like a drum
it's like a little membrane you've got
this hammer attached to it
and that hammer has three parts for
those of you that want to know those
three parts are called
malleus incus and stapes it's like but
basically just think about it as a
hammer so you've got this eardrum
and then a hammer and then that hammer
has to hammer on something and what it
does is it hammers
on a little coiled piece of tissue
that we call the cochlea sometimes
called the cochlea depending on where
somebody lives in the country so
typically in the midwest on the east
coast they call them cochlea
and on the west coast we call them
cochlea same thing
okay so this snail-shaped structure in
your inner ear
is where sound gets converted into
electrical signals that the brain can
understand
but i want to just bring your attention
to that little hammer
because that little hammer is really
really cool what it means is that sound
waves come in through your ears that's
what's happening right now
that eardrum that you have is like a
it's like the top of a drum it's like a
membrane or it can move back and forth
it's not super rigid
and it moves that little hammer and then
the hammer goes
and hits this coil shaped thing that
we're calling the cochlea
okay now the cochlea
at one end is more rigid than the other
so one part can move really easily and
the other part
doesn't move very easily and that turns
out to be very important for decoding
or separating sounds that are low
frequency like costello's snoring
and sounds that are of high frequency
like a shriek or a shrill
and that's because within that
little coiled thing we call the cochlea
you have all these
tiny little what are called hair cells
now they look like hairs but they're not
at all related to the hairs on your head
or
elsewhere on your body they're just
shaped like hair so we call them hair
cells
those hair cells if they move
send signals into the brain that a
particular sound is in our environment
and if those hair cells don't move it
means that particular sound
is not in our environment okay so just
to give you the mental picture of this
sound waves are coming in because
there's stuff out there making noises
like my voice
it's changing the patterns of air around
you in
very very subtle ways that information
is getting funneled
into your ears because your pinnas are
shaped in a particular way
the eardrum then moves this little
hammer and the hammer bangs on this
little snail shaped thing
and because that snail shaped thing at
one end
is very rigid it doesn't want to move
and at the other end it's very flexible
it can separate out high frequency and
low frequency sounds
and the fact that this thing in your
inner ear that we call the cochlea is
coiled is actually really important to
understand
because along its length it varies in
how rigid or flexible it is i already
mentioned that before and at the base
it's very rigid and that's where
the hair cells if they move will make
high frequency sounds
and at the top what's called the apex
it's very flexible
and it's more like a bass drum so
basically what happens is sound waves
come into your ears
and then at one end of this thing that
we call the cochlea
at the top it's essentially encoding or
only responding to sounds are like
whereas at the bottom it responds to
high frequency sounds
like a symbol
okay and everywhere in between we have
other frequencies
medium frequencies now this should
stagger your mind if it doesn't already
it should
because what this means is that
everything that's happening around us
whether or not it's music or voices or
crying or screaming or screaming of
delight from small children who are
excited because they're playing or
because they get cake
all of that is being broken down into
its component parts
and then your brain is making sense of
what it means
these things that i've been talking
about like the pin of your ears and this
little hammer and the cochlea that's all
purely mechanical
it has no mind of its own it's just
breaking things down into
high frequencies medium frequencies and
low frequencies and if you don't
understand sound frequency it's really
simple to understand
just imagine ripples on a pond and if
those ripples are
very close together that's high
frequency they occur at
high frequency if those ripples are
further apart
it's low frequency and obviously medium
frequency is in between so just like you
can have waves in water you can have
waves in air
so that's that's really how it works now
we're all we are all familiar with light
and how if you take a prism and put it
in front of light
it will split that light into its
different wavelengths it's different
colors
red green blue etc right sort of like
the pink floyd
dark side of the moon album i think has
a prism and it's
converting white light into all the
colors
all the wavelengths that are contained
in white light your cochlea essentially
acts as a prism it takes all the sound
in your environment and it splits up
those sounds
into different frequencies so you can
think of the cochlea of your ear sort of
like a prism
and then the brain takes that
information and puts it back together
and makes sense of it
so those hair cells in each of your two
cochlea
because you have two ears you also have
two cochlea
send little wires what we call axons
that convey their patterns of activity
into the brain and there are a number of
different stations
within the brain that information
arrives at before it gets up to the
parts of your brain
where you are consciously aware and
because some of you have asked for more
names and nomenclature i'll give that to
you if you don't want
a lot of detailed names you can just
ignore what i'm about to say but
basically the cochlea
send information to what's called the
spiral ganglion
the spiral gang a ganglion by the way if
you're going to learn any neuroscience
just know that anytime you hear
ganglion a ganglion is just a clump
so it means a bunch of neurons so a
clump of cells
so the spiral ganglion is a bunch of
neurons that
the information then goes off to what
are called the cochlear nuclei
in the brain stem brain stem is kind of
down near your neck then up to a
structure that has a really cool name
called the superior olive because it uh
you have one on each side of your brain
um and if i were to bring you to my lab
and show you the superior olives in
your brain or anyone else's brain they
look like little olives
they even have a little divot in them
that to me looks like a pimiento but
they just called them the super the
superior olive
and then the the neurons in the superior
olive then they send information up to
what's called the inferior colliculus
only called inferior because it sits
below
a structure called the superior
colliculus and then the information goes
up to what's called the medial
geniculate
nucleus and then up to your neocortex
where you make
sense of it all now you don't have to
remember all that but
you should know that there are a lot of
stations
in which auditory information is
processed before it gets up to our
conscious detection and there
is a good reason for that which is that
more
important than knowing what you're
hearing you need to know
where it's coming from it's vital to our
survival
that if something for instance is
falling toward us that we know if it's
coming to our right side if it's going
to hit us from behind
we have to know for instance if a car is
is coming at us from our left or from
our right
and our visual system can help with that
but our auditory and our visual system
collaborate to help us
find and locate the position of things
in space
that should come as no surprise if you
hear somebody
talking off to your right you tend to
turn to your right not to your left
if you see somebody's mouth moving in
front of you you tend to assume that the
sound is going to come from right in
front of you
disruptions in this auditory
hearing and visual matching are actually
the basis of what's called the
ventriloquism effect which we'll talk
about in a few minutes
in more depth but the ventriloquism
effect can basically be described in
simple terms as
when you essentially think that a sound
is coming from a location
that it's not actually coming from
we'll talk about that in a moment but
what i'd like you to realize is that
one of these stations deep in your brain
stem is responsible for helping you
identify
where sounds are coming from through a
process that's called
inter-oral time differences and that
sounds fancy but really
the way you know where things are coming
from what direction a car or a boss or a
person is coming from
is because the sound lands in one ear
before the other
and you have stations in your brain and
you meaning you have neurons in your
brain that calculate the difference in
time of arrival for those sound waves in
your right versus your left ear
and if they arrive at the same time you
assume that thing
is making noise right in front of you if
it's off to your right
you assume it's over on your right and
if the sound arrives first to your left
ear
you assume quite correctly that the
thing is coming toward
your left ear so it's a very simple and
kind of a mechanical system
at the level of sound localization
but what about up and down if you think
about it a sound coming from above is
going to land on your right ear and your
left ear at the same time
a sound from below is going to land on
your right ear and your left ear at the
same time
so the way that we know where things are
in terms of what's called elevation
where they are
in the up and down plane
is by the frequencies the shape of your
ears
actually modifies the sound depending on
whether or not it's coming straight at
you
from the floor or from high above and so
already at the level of your ears you
are
taking information about the outside
world and determining
where that information is coming from
now this all happens very very fast in
subconscious
but now you know why if people really
want to hear
something they make a cup
around their ear they essentially make
their ear into more of a fennec
fox type ear if you've ever seen those
cute little fennec fox things
they have these big spiky ears they kind
of look like a french bulldog
although they're kind of the fox version
version of the french bulldog
these big big tall ears and they have
excellent sound localization
and so when people lean in with their
you're like with their hand like this
if you're listening to this i'm just
cupping my hand at my ear i'm giving
myself a bigger
pinna okay and if i do it on the left
side i do this side
and if i really want to hear something i
do it on both sides
okay so this isn't just gesturing this
actually serves a mechanical role
and actually if you want to hear where
things are coming from with a much
greater degree
of accuracy this can actually help
because you're capturing sound waves and
funneling them
better it's really remarkable this whole
system
so you've got these two ears and because
of the differences in the timing of when
things arrive in those two years
as well as these differences in the
frequencies of
that certain things sound or i should
say
the differences in the frequencies that
arrive at your ears depending on whether
or not the
thing is above you or right in front of
you or below you you're able to make out
where things are in space
pretty well so now you're probably
starting to realize that these two
things on the side of our head that we
call ears
are there for a lot more than hanging
earrings on
or for other aesthetic purposes or for
putting sunglasses
on top of they are very
powerful devices for allowing us to
capture sound waves
from our environment now i have a
question for you
which is can you move your ears
turns out that unlike other animals
humans are not terrifically good at
moving their ears
other animals can move their ears even
independently
so costello is pretty good at raising
his ears the two of them together he
can't really move
his ears separately some dogs can do
that really well
in fact sight hounds and some scent
hounds do that exquisitely well
some animals like deer and other animals
that
really have a very acute hearing
will put one ear down to a very
particular angle and will tilt the other
one and they will actually
capture information about two distant
sound making organisms those could be
hunters coming after them or other
animals coming after them
they are very good at doing this we're
not so good at it but
about 60 percent of people it's thought
can
move their ears consciously without
having to touch their ears so can you do
that
maybe you should try it ask someone to
look at you and see whether or not you
can do it
the typical distances that people can
move it is
usually no more than two or three
millimeters it's subtle but can you flap
your pinna
with uh just using mental control if you
can
or if you can't try
looking all the way to your right or all
the way to your left if obviously if
you're driving a car or doing something
or exercising
don't put yourself in danger right now
but if you move your eyes all the way to
your
left which i'm doing now or all the way
to my right
you might feel a little bit of a
contraction of the muscles it's a
that control ear movement
all right now i want to ask you this can
you raise one eyebrow
i'm not very good at i can do a little
bit but it's mostly by like
cramping down my face on one side and i
certainly can't raise my
right eyebrow i can only do my like left
eyebrow trying to talk while i'm doing
this so that's why it looks strange
people who can raise one eyebrow very
easily
almost always can move their ears
without having to touch them
it's controlled by the same motor
pathway
and there does seem to be a small but
statistically significant sex difference
in the ability to move one's ears
typically
men can do this more than women can
although plenty of women can move their
ears as well
now if you think that is all a little
strange or off topic it's not because
what we're really talking about here is
a system
of the brain but also of the body of the
musculature for localizing things in
space
and so it you might find it interesting
to note that
one of the things that we share very
closely
with other primates with non-human
primates like macaque monkeys and
chimpanzees
if you look at their ears their ears are
remarkably similar
to our ears or rather our ears are
remarkably similar to their ears
the eyes of certain monkeys like macaque
monkeys are remarkably similar to human
eyes
this is one of the reasons why if you
look at a baby macaque monkey it
look it has this unbelievably human
element to it
but the ears of these primates is very
similar to our to our
ears our ears similar to their ears
if you're interested in ear movements
and
what they could mean and some of the
things that ear movements correlate with
in other aspects of our biology there's
a nice paper actually scientific paper
uh the the author's last name is code
c-o-d-e
it was published in 1995. i'll give a
reference to that it's a review article
that discusses some of the sex
differences in ear movement control
as well as the relationship between ear
movements and eye movements
and it's a pretty accessible paper it's
one that i think any of you
who are interested in this topic could
um could parse fairly easily
and there's some very interesting
underlying biology and some theories as
to
why humans would have this so-called
vestigial or
ancient carryover of a system for moving
our ears
now if ear movement seems
strange next i want to talk about a
different feature
of your hearing and ears that's even
stranger but that has some really
interesting implications
for your biology and i'm guessing
that you've not heard of this
what i'm about to describe are called
auto acoustic emissions
and auto acoustic emissions as the name
suggests
are sounds that your ears make
believe it or not 70 of people
make noises with their ears but they
don't actually
detect them like i said you've never
heard of this okay that's
that's not what i mean but what i do
mean is that
70 of people's ears are making noise
that's cast
out of the ear and these auto acoustic
emissions actually can be detected by
microphones
sometimes they can be detected by other
people in the room if they have very
good hearing
now it turns out that women
or i should be technical here females
who report as
themselves as heterosexual have a
higher frequency not frequency of sound
but a
higher frequency of auto-acoustic
emissions than do
men who report themselves as
heterosexual women
who report themselves as homosexual or
bisexual
make fewer auto acoustic emissions than
heterosexual women
these are data that come from dennis
mcfadden's lab at the university of
texas austin
he actually discovered these what are
called sexual dimorphisms
and differences based on sexual
orientation
without looking for them he was studying
hearing he's a auditory
scientist and people were coming into
his laboratory and they were detecting
these autoacoustic emissions and they
started to
notice the group differences in
auto-acoustic emission so they started
asking people
about their sex and about their sexual
orientation
and these differences fell out of the
data
as we say and it's interesting because
auto acoustic emissions are not
something that we associate with
sex or sexual dimorphism but what these
data really underscore
is first of all a lot of us are making
noises with our ears
some of us more than others and that
exposure to certain combinations of
hormones during development
are very likely shaping the way that our
hearing
apparati meaning the cochlea and the
pinna and all sorts of things
how those develop and how those function
throughout the lifespan we did do an
episode
on hormones and sexual development which
gets
much deeper into the other effects that
hormones have on the developing brain
and body
if you want to check out that episode we
will put a link to it
in the captions so now i want to shift
to talking about
ways to leverage your hearing system
your auditory system
so that you can learn anything not just
auditory information but anything
faster i get a lot of questions about
so-called
binaural beats binaural beats as their
name suggests
involve playing one frequency of sound
to one ear and a different frequency of
sound to the other ear
so it might be
to your right ear and it might be
to the left ear and the idea is that
the brain will take those two
frequencies of sound
and because the pathways that bring
information from the ears into the brain
eventually cross over they actually
share that information with both sides
of the brain
that the brain will average that
information and
come up with a sort of intermediate
frequency and the rationale is that
those intermediate frequencies
place the brain into a state that is
better for learning
and when i say better for learning i
want to be precise about what i mean
that could mean more focus for encoding
or or
bringing the information in we as you
may have heard me say before we have to
be alert and focused in order to learn
there is no passive learning unless
we're little tiny infants
so can binaural beats make us more
focused
can binaural beats allow us to relax
more if we're anxious
i know some people they go to the
dentist and the dentist offers binaural
beats
as they drill into your teeth and give
root canals and things of that sort
probably causing some anxiety just
describing those those things right now
but those are available in several
dentists many dental practices
their binaural beats have been thought
to increase creativity
or at least have been proposed to
increase creativity so what are the
scientific data say about binaural beats
there are a number of different apps out
there
of that offer binaural beats there are a
number of different programs you can i
think you can also even just find these
on
on youtube and on the internet but
typically it's an app
and you'll program in a particular
outcome that you want more focused more
creative fall asleep
less anxious etc so what do the
scientific data say
so believe it or not the science on
binaural beats is actually quite
extensive
and very precise so sound waves
are measured typically in hertz or
kilohertz i know many of you aren't
familiar with thinking about things in
hertz or kilohertz but again just
remember those waves on a pond
those ripples on a pond if they're close
together
then they are of high frequency and if
they're far apart then they are low
frequency so when you hear more hurts
what you're essentially hearing is
higher frequency
right and so if it's many more kilohertz
then it's much higher frequency than if
it's fewer hertz or killer hertz
and so you may have heard of these
things as delta waves or theta waves or
alpha waves or beta waves etc
delta waves would be big slow waves a
low frequency
and indeed there is quality evidence
from peer-reviewed studies that are not
sponsored by companies that make
binaural beat apps that tell us that
delta waves like one to four hertz so
very low frequency sounds think
costello's snoring
can help in the the transition to sleep
and for
staying asleep and that theta rhythms
which are
more like 48 hertz can bring the brain
into a state
of subtle sleep
or meditation so deeply relaxed but not
fully asleep
and then you can sort of ascend the
staircase of findings here so to speak
and you'll find evidence that alpha
waves 8 to 13 hertz can
increase alertness to a moderate level
that's a great state for the brain to be
in
for recall of existing information
okay and that beta waves 15 to 20 hertz
are great for bringing the brain into
focus states
for sustained thought or for
incorporating
new information and especially gamma
waves the highest frequency the most
frequent ripples of sound
so to speak 32 to 100 hertz for learning
and problem solving now all of this
matches
or i should say maps onto what i've said
before about learning
really nicely which is that you need to
be in a highly alert state in order to
bring new information in
in order to access a state of mind in
which you can
tell your brain or the brain is telling
itself okay i need to learn this this is
why stress and unfortunate circumstances
are so memorable is because our brain
gets into a really high alert system
here we're talking about the use of
binaural beats in order to increase
our level of alertness or al or our
level of calmness
now that's important to underscore
because it's not that there's something
fundamentally important
about the binaural beats they are yet
another way of bringing the brain into
states of
deep relaxation through low frequency
sound or
highly alert states for focused learning
with
more high frequency sound so they are
effective
and i'll review a little bit of the data
in detail
they're effective but it's not that
they're uniquely special
for learning it's just that they can
help some people
bring their brain into the state that
allows them to learn
better so there are a lot of studies
that
allowed us to arrive or i should say
allow the field to arrive
on these parameters of you know slow
slow
low frequency waves are going to bring
you into relaxed states high frequency
waves into more
alert states there's very good evidence
for anxiety reduction from the use of
binaural beats
and what's interesting is the the
anxiety reduction seems to be
most effective when the binaural beats
are bringing the brain into delta so
those slow
big waves like sleep theta and alpha
states
and i'll link to a couple of these
studies although i will probably link
um more to the list that really
segregates them out
one by one so you can see them all next
to one another there's good evidence
that binaural beats can be used to treat
pain
chronic pain there's three studies in
peer-reviewed journals which i took a
look at and they seem to be
of good quality not sponsored research
as we say not not paid for by any
specific company
binaural beats have been shown to
modestly improve cognition
attention working memory and even
creativity
but the real boost from binaural beats
appears to be
for anxiety reduction and pain reduction
some people might find these beneficial
for these oral surgeries
right believe it or not there are people
who would rather
have the entire root canal or cavity
drilled without novocaine
and that's because they sometimes have a
syringe phobia or something of that sort
or they just don't like being numb from
the novocaine or maybe there's an
underlying medical reason
but i think most people do don't enjoy
getting their teeth drilled even if they
have novocaine in there or a root canal
and so it seems that binaural beats can
be effective in that environment
and you don't have to go into that sort
of extreme environment to benefit from
binaural beats binaural beats
are a either relatively
inexpensive thing to access most of the
apps are pretty inexpensive
i don't have a favorite binaural beats
app to recommend to you
i confess i did use binaural beats a few
years ago i kind of shifted over to
other what what i call nsdr non-sleep
deep breast protocols in favor of those
but many people like binaural beats and
say that they benefit from them
especially while studying or learning i
think part of the reason for that
relates to the ability to channel our
focus
when we have some background noise and
this is something i also get asked about
a lot
is it better to listen to music and have
background noise
when studying or is it better to have
complete silence well
there's actually a quite good literature
on this as well
but not so much as it relates to
binaural beats but rather
whether or not people are listening to
music so-called
white noise brown noise believe it or
not there's white noise and there's
brown noise there's even pink noise
and how that impacts brain states that
allow us to learn information
better or not so now i'd like to talk
about white
noise and i want to be very clear that
white noise has been shown to really
enhance
brain states for learning in certain
individuals
in particular in adults but white noise
actually can have
a detrimental effect on auditory
learning and maybe even the development
of the auditory system
in very young children in particular in
infants
so first i'd like to talk about the
beneficial effects of white noise on
learning
there are some really excellent studies
on this
the first one that i'd like to just
highlight
is one that's entitled low intensity
white noise improves performance in
auditory working memory tasks an fmri
study this is a study that
explored whether or not learning could
be
enhanced by playing white noise in the
background
but the strength of the study is that
they looked at some of the underlying
neural
circuitry and the activation of the
neural circuitry in these people as they
did
the learning task and what it
essentially illustrates
is that white noise provided that white
noise
is of low enough intensity meaning not
super loud
right not imperceptible so not so quiet
that you can't hear it
but not super loud either it actually
could enhance learning to a significant
degree
and this has been shown now for a huge
number of different
types of learning there's a terrific
article
as well as in a somewhat obscure journal
at least obscure to me which is the
effects of noise exposure on cognitive
performance and brain
activity patterns that's a study
involving 54 subjects
they basically were evaluated for mental
workload and attention under different
levels of noise exposure
background noise and different
essentially loudness of noise and the
reason i like this study is that they
looked at different levels of noise and
types of noise and they varied a number
of different
things as opposed to just doing a kind
of two condition either white noise or
no white noise type thing
and what they found again is that
provided the white noise
is not extremely loud it could really
enhance brain function
for sake of learning any number of
different kinds of information
now that's all great but it really
doesn't get to
the kind of deeper guts of mechanism and
as a neuroscientist
what i really want to see is not just
that something has an effect that's
always nice it's always nice to see in a
nice
peer-reviewed study without any kind of
commercial biases that there's an effect
okay binaural beats can enhance learning
or
listening to white noise not too loud
can enhance learning
but you really want to understand
mechanism because once you understand
mechanism not only does it start to make
sense but you can also imagine ways in
which
you could develop better tools and
protocols so i was very
relieved to find or i should say excited
to find
this study published in the journal of
cognitive neuroscience
this is a 2014 paper
white noise improves learning by
modulating activity in dopaminergic
midbrain regions
and the right superior temporal sulcus
okay i don't expect you to know what the
right spirit temporal sulcus is
i don't expect you to know what the
dopamine midbrain region is but
if you're like me you probably took
highlighted notice of the word
dopaminergic dopamine
is a neuromodulator meaning it's a
chemical that's released in our brain
and body but mostly in our brain
that modulates meaning controls
the likelihood that certain brain areas
will be active and other brain areas
won't be active
and dopamine is associated with
motivation dopamine is associated with
craving
motivation is associated with all sorts
of different things including movement
but what this study so nicely shows
is that white noise can
really enhance the activity of neurons
in what's called the substantia
vta the substantia of eta is a
very rich source of dopamine and
that's because it's very chock-a-block
full of dopamine neurons
it's an area of the brain that is
perhaps the richest source
of dopamine neurons and you actually can
see this brain region under the
microscope
if you take a slice of brain or you look
at a brain without even staining it for
any proteins or dopamine or anything
it's a two very dark regions at the kind
of bottom of the brain
and the reason it's called substantia
meaning dark
is because the dopamine neurons actually
make something
and that makes those neurons dark and so
you've got these two regions down there
can that contain dopamine and can
release dopamine and essentially
activate other brain regions and
activate our sense of motivation and
activate our sense of
desire to continue focusing and learning
but
you can't just snap your fingers and
make them release dopamine you actually
have to trigger dopamine release from
them now that
trigger can be caused by being very
excited about something
or the fact that that thing gave you a
lot of pleasure in the past or you're
highly motivated
by fear or desire but what's so
interesting to me is that it appears
that white noise itself can raise the
what we call the basal the baseline
levels of dopamine that are being
released
from this area the substantia so
now we're starting to get a more full
picture of how particular
sounds in our environment can increase
learning and that's in part i believe
through
the release of dopamine from substantia
so i'm not trying to shift you away from
binaural beats if that's your thing
but it does appear that turning on white
noise at a low level not too loud you
may say well how loud and i'll tell you
in a moment
but not too loud can allow you to learn
better
because of the ways that it's modulating
your brain chemistry
so how loud or how soft should that
white noise be
while you learn well in these studies
it seemed that white noise that could be
heard by the person so it wasn't
imperceptible to them so it was loud
enough that they could hear
but not so loud that they felt
it was intrusive or irritating to them
okay so that's going to differ from
person to person because people have
different levels of auditory
sensitivity it's going to depend on age
gonna depend on a number of different
factors
so i can't tell you you know turn to
level two on your volume controller
that's just not gonna work also i don't
know how far you are from a given
speaker in the room
or if you got earphones in your head or
you've got
speakers in the room or if it's coming
out of your computer i don't know those
things
so what you're gonna have to do is
adjust that white noise to a place where
it's not interfering with your ability
to focus but rather
it's enhancing your ability to focus i
think a good rule of thumb
is going to be to put it probably in the
lower third of any kind of volume dial
as opposed to in the upper you know
upper third where
it would really be blasting and really
blasting
any noise frankly is not good but that's
especially
not good meaning it's especially bad if
you have headphones in
i do want to mention something about
headphones before i talk about
white noise in the developmental context
and why it can be dangerous there
when you put headphones in your ears
it has this incredible effect of
making the sounds like they come from
inside your head not from out in the
room
and now that might seem like kind of a
duh but that's actually really amazing
right your brain assumes that the sounds
are coming from inside your head
as opposed from the environment that
you're in the moment you put headphones
in
so if you're listening to an audio book
or maybe you're listening to this
podcast with headphones
that's very different than when you're
listening to something out in the room
and there are other sounds
other sound waves especially if you use
these noise cancellation headphones
so if you're going to use white noise to
enhance studying or learning of any kind
and this also could be for skill
learning motor skill learning while
you're exercising
my suggestion would be that if you're
using headphones to keep it quite low
right this is an effect on the midbrain
dopamine neurons
that's a background effect of raising
the baseline of dopamine release the way
that dopamine neurons fires they're
always firing yours are firing right now
so are mine
when something exciting happens they
fire a lot and when something
disappointing happens that firing
the release of dopamine goes down below
baseline what you're talking about here
is raising your overall levels of
attention and motivation which translate
to better learning
by just tickling those neurons a little
bit raising the bass line firing
okay so this isn't you're not turning up
the white noise to the point where
you're feeling amazing this isn't like
turning on your favorite song
this is actually the opposite this is
about getting that bass line
up just a bit okay so i recommend
turning it
the volume up just a bit so that you can
focus
entirely on the tasks that you're trying
to do and of course you've turned on
white noise so your attention might
drift to that for a moment is it too
loud is it too soft
if you can disappear into the work so to
speak if your attention can disappear
into the work
then that's probably sufficiently quiet
and for those of you that say well i
like really loud music and if i just
blast the music
then i forget about the music i don't
suggest blasting music and this is
coming from somebody who really likes
loud
you know loud music you know i grew up
with kind of a loud fast rules mentality
and if you don't know what loud fast
rules means um
then i can't help you but you
it there's a time and a place perhaps to
listen to music loud but especially with
headphones
you can trigger head you can trigger
excuse me hearing loss
quite rapidly and unfortunately because
these hair cells that we talked about
earlier are central nervous system
neurons they do not
regenerate they do not come back now
along the lines of hearing loss i should
just say that
the best way to blow out your hearing
for good to eliminate your hearing
is to have very loud sounds superimposed
on a loud environment
okay so loud environments can cause
hearing loss over time so if you work at
a construction site
clanging really loud or if you're if you
uh work the sound board and in a club or
something you are headed towards
hearing loss unless you protect your
your hearing with
with ear plugs and headphones um
nowadays some of the the earplugs are
very low profile meaning you can't see
them so that's kind of nice so you're
not like the
like when i was younger like you didn't
want to be the dork to go to the concert
with the earplugs but
turns out those dorks were smarter than
everybody else because they're not the
ones who are
you know craning their neck to try and
hear trivial things
um at the age of you know uh 30 or so
because they blew out their hearing
so if you are in working in a loud
environment or you expose yourselves
to a loud environment you really want to
avoid
big inflections and sound above that so
loud environment plus fireworks loud
environment plus gunshot
loud and loud environments plus very
high frequency intense sound that
that's what we call the two-hit model
when you this is also true for
concussion that you can take a
kind of a stimulus that normally would
be below the threshold of injury you add
some another stimulus at the same time
that would be below the threshold of
injury and then suddenly you killed the
neurons
so i i don't want to make people
paranoid but you do want to protect your
hearing it's no fun to lose your hearing
if you're going to use headphones and
you feel like you want to crank it up
all the way just remember
that the more that you can get out of a
lower volume meaning the longer that you
can go listening to
things at lower volume the longer you'll
be able to hear
that music or that thing so
again i'm not i'm not the hearing cop
that's not my job
but uh as somebody who's lost some of
his uh high frequency hearing
i can tell you it's it's it's not a
pleasure um
it the the old argument that it helps
you not have to
hear or listen to people that you don't
want to listen to that does it doesn't
really work they just send you text
messages instead
so what about white noise and hearing
loss and development
i know a lot of people with children
have these kind of noise
machines like sound waves and things
like that that help the kids sleep
and look i i think kids getting good
sleep and parents getting good sleep is
vital to
physical and mental health and family
health so i
i certainly sympathize with with those
needs
however there are data that indicate
that
white noise during development can be
detrimental to the auditory system
i don't want to frighten any parents if
you played white noise to your kids
this doesn't mean that their auditory
system or their speech patterns are
going to be disrupted
or that their interpretation of speech
is going to be disrupted forever
but there are data published in the
journal science
in science being one of the three apex
journals science nature cell
the most stringent journals data
published in the journal science
some years ago actually by a scientist
who i know quite well his name is edward
chang he's a medical doctor now he's a
neurosurgeon he's actually the chair of
neurosurgery
at ucsf and he runs a laboratory where
they study
auditory learning neuroplasticity et
cetera
he and his mentor at the time mike
merzinek published a paper showing
that if young animals and this wasn't
animal models
were exposed to white noise so
shh the very type of noise that i'm
saying
as a older person so and when i say
older i mean somebody
who's in their late teens early 20s and
older could benefit from listening to
that at a low level in the background
for sake of learning well when they
exposed very young animals to this white
noise
it actually disrupted the maps of
the auditory world within the brain now
we haven't talked about these maps yet
but i want to take a moment and talk
about them and explain this effect and
what it might mean
for you if you have kids or if you were
exposed to a lot of white noise early on
so auditory information goes up into our
cortex
into these the essentially the outside
portion of our brain that's responsible
for all our
all of our how higher level cognition
our planning our decision making etc
creativity and up there we have what are
called
tonotopic maps what's a tonatopic map
well
remember the cochlea how it's coiled and
at one end it responds to high
frequencies in the other end it responds
to low frequencies sort of like a piano
the keys sound different as you extend
down and up the piano keys and it's
organized in a very
systematic way right it's not all
intermixed high frequencies and low
frequencies it's
it's organized in a very systematic way
from one end to the other
your visual system is in what's called a
retinotopic map so
neighboring points in space off to my
right like my two fingers off to my
right
are mapped to neighboring points in
space in
my brain and the space right in front of
me is mapped to a different location in
my brain but it's systematic it's
regular it's not random it's not
salt and pepper it goes from high to
lower from right to center to left
in the auditory system we have what are
called tonatopic maps
where frequency high frequency to low
frequency and everything in between is
organized in a very systematic way now
our experience of life from the time
we're a baby until the time that we
die is not systematic we don't hear low
frequencies at one part of the room or
at one part of the day and high
frequency is another part of the room
another part of the day
they're all intermixed but if you
remember the cochlea separates them out
just like a prism of light separates out
the different wavelengths of light the
cochlea separates out the different
frequencies
and the developing brain takes those
separated out frequencies and
learns this relationship between
itself meaning the child and the outside
world
white noise essentially contains no
tonatopic information the frequencies
are all intermixed
it's just noise whereas when i speak my
voice has
now i'm getting technical but it has
what's called a certain envelope meaning
it has some low frequencies
and some slightly high frequencies like
i make my voice higher although i'm not
very good at that my way starts to crack
and i can make my voice lower although
not as low as costello snores so it has
an envelope
it has a container white noise has no
container it's like all the colors of
the rainbow
spread out together which is actually
what you get when you get white light
white noise is analogous to white light
so one of the reasons
why hearing a lot of white noise during
development for long periods of time can
be detrimental to the development of the
auditory system is that these tonotopic
maps don't form normally
at least they don't in experimental
animals now
the reason i'm raising this is that many
people i know in particular friends
who have small children they say i want
to use a white noise
machine while i sleep but is is it okay
for my baby to use a white noise machine
and i consulted with various people
scientists about this and they said well
you know the baby is also hearing the
parents voices and is hearing music and
is hearing the dog bark so
it's not the only thing they're hearing
however every single
person that i consulted with said but
you know
there's neuroplasticity during sleep
that's when the kid is sleeping
and i don't know that you'd want to
expose a child to white noise the
entire night because it might
degrade that tonotopic map it might not
destroy it
it might not eliminate it but it could
make it a little
less clear like sort of taking the keys
on the piano
and taping a few of them together right
so you still got the highs and lows in
the appropriate order
and everything in between but when you
tape the keys together you don't get the
same fidelity you don't get the same
precision
of the noise that comes out of that
piano
so i'm i don't again i don't want to
scare anybody but i would say if you are
in a position to
make the choice of either using white
noise or something similar
pink noise is just a kind of variation
it's got a little bit more of a certain
frequency
just like pink light has a little bit
more of a certain wavelength than white
light kind of
if you are in a position to make
choices about things to put in a
young especially very young child
sleeping environment
white noise might be something to
consider avoiding
again i'm not telling you what to do but
it's something to perhaps consider
avoiding
i don't think most pediatricians are
going to be aware of these data
but if you talk to any auditory
physiologist or an audiologist or
somebody who studies auditory
development
i'm fairly certain that they would have
opinions about that now whether or not
their opinions agree with
mine and these folks that i consulted
with or not is a separate matter i don't
know because i don't know them
but it's something that i felt was
important enough to cue you to
especially since i've highlighted i've
highlighted
excuse me the opposite effect is true in
adulthood once your auditory system has
formed once it's established these
tonatopic maps then the presence of
background
white noise should not be a problem at
all in fact it shouldn't be a problem at
all
because you're also not attending to it
the idea is that it's playing at a low
enough volume that you kind of forget it
in the background
and that it's supporting learning by
bringing your brain into a heightened
state of alertness and especially this
heightened state of dopamine
dopaminergic activation of the brain
which will make it easier to learn
faster and easier to learn the
information
so now i want to talk about auditory
learning and actually how you can get
better at learning information that you
hear
not just information that you see on a
page or
motor skill learning there are a lot of
reasons to want to do this a lot of
classroom teaching
whether or not it's by zoom or in person
is auditory in nature not
everything is necessarily written down
for us
it's also good to get better at
listening
or so i'm told so there's a phenomenon
called
the cocktail party effect now even if
you've never been to a cocktail party
you've experienced
and participated in what's called the
cocktail party effect the cocktail party
effect is where you are in an
environment that's rich with sound
many sound waves coming from many
different sources many different things
so
in a city in a classroom in a car that
contains people having various
conversations
you somehow need to be able to attend to
specific components of those sound waves
meaning you need to hear
certain people and not others the reason
it's called the cocktail party effect
is that you and meaning your brain
are exquisitely good at
creating a cone of auditory attention a
narrow band of attention
with which you can extract the
information you care about
and wipe away or erase all the rest
now this takes work it takes attention
one of the reasons why you might come
home from a loud gathering maybe a
stadium a sports event or a cocktail
party for that matter
and feel just exhausted is because if
you were listening to conversations
there or trying to listen to those
conversations while watching the game
and
people moving past you and hearing all
this noise clinking of glasses etc
it takes attentional effort and the
brain
uses up a lot of energy just at rest but
it uses up even
more energy when you are paying strong
attention to something
literally caloric energy burning up
things like glucose etc even if you're
ketogenic it's burning up energy
so the cocktail party effect has been
studied
extensively in the field of neuroscience
and we now know at a mechanistic level
how one accomplishes this feat of
attending to certain sounds
despite the fact that we are being
bombarded with all sorts of other sounds
so there are a couple ways that we do
this first of all
much as with our visual system
we can expand or contract
our visual field of view so we can go
from
panoramic vision see the entire scene
that we're we are in by dilating our
gaze
talked a lot about this on this podcast
and elsewhere we can
for instance keep our head and eyes
stationary or mostly stationary you
don't have to be rigid about it you can
expand your field of view so you can see
the walls and ceiling and floor
you can see yourself in the environment
that's panoramic view it's what you
would accomplish without having to try
at all if you
went to a horizon for instance or we can
contract our field of view i can bring
my focus to a particular location when
we call a virgin's point directly in
front of me now i'm pointing at the
camera directly in front of me
okay we can do that we can expand and
contract our visual field of view well
we can expand and contract our auditory
field of view so to speak or our
auditory window
you can try this next time you are in an
environment that's rich with noise
meaning lots of different sounds you can
just tune out
all the noise to a background chatter
you kind of just
you try not focus on any one particular
sound
and you get the background kind of
chatter of noise
and you'll find it's actually very
relaxing in comparison to trying to
listen to somebody at a cocktail party
you're shouting back and forth now if
you're very very interested in that
person
or getting to know them better or what
they're telling you
or some combination of those things then
you'll be very motivated to do it but
nonetheless it requires
energy and effort and attention
how do we do this well it's actually
quite simple
or at least it's simple in essence
although the underlying mechanisms
are complex here i have to
credit the laboratory of a guy named
mike weir
w-e-h-r up at the university of oregon
who essentially figured out that
we are able to accomplish this
extraction of particular sounds we can
we can really hear one person or a small
number of people
amidst a huge background of chatter
because
we pay attention to the onset of words
but also to the offset of words
now the way to visualize this is if the
background noise is just like a bunch of
waves of noise it's
literally just sound waves coming every
frequency low frequency high frequency
glasses clinking together if you had a
game people are shouting
people are talking on their phone
there's the crack of the ball if
somebody
you know actually manages to to hit the
ball
oh the announcer etc but
whatever we're paying attention to we
set up a cone of auditory attention a
kind of
a tunnel of auditory attention where we
are listening although we don't realize
it we are listening for the onset
and the offset of those words
now this is powerful for a couple of
reasons first of all
it's a call to arm so to speak to
disengage your auditory system when you
don't need to focus your attention on
something
particular so if you are somebody you're
coming home from work you've had a very
long day
and you're trying to make out a
particular conversation
on background noise you might consider
just
not having that conversation just
letting your auditory
landscape be very broad almost like
panoramic vision
if you're trying to learn how to extract
sound information it could be notes of
music
it could be scales of music it could be
words spoken by somebody else maybe
somebody is telling you
what you need to say for a particular
speech or the information that you need
to learn
for a particular topic and they're
telling it to you
deliberately paying attention both to
the onset and to the offset of those
words
can be beneficial because it it is
exactly the way that the auditory system
likes to bring in information so
one of the more common phenomena that i
think we all experience is you go to a
party
and or you meet somebody new and you say
hi i would say hi i'm andrew and they'd
say hi
i'm i'm jeff for instance great great to
meet you and then a minute later
i can't remember the guy's name now is
it because i don't care what his name is
no
somehow the presence of other auditory
information
interfered it's not that my mind was
necessarily someplace else it's that
the signal to noise as we say wasn't
high enough somehow the way he said it
or the way it landed on my ears which is
really all that matters
right when when it comes down to
learning is
such that it just didn't achieve high
enough signal to noise the noise was too
high or the signal was too low or some
combination of those
so the next time you ask somebody's name
remember listen to the onset
of what they say and the offsets it
would be paying attention to the
j in jeff and it would be paying
attention to that
in f in jeff excuse me all right
and chances are you'll be able to
remember that name
now i don't know if people who are super
learners
of names do this naturally or not i
don't have access to their brains
i don't think they're going to give me
access to their brains either but
it's a very interesting way to take the
natural biology of auditory attention
and learning
and apply it to scenarios where you're
trying to remember either people's names
or specific information now i do
acknowledge that trying to learn
every word in a sentence by paying
attention
to its onset and offset could actually
be kind of disruptive to the learning
process
so this would be more for specific
attention like you're asking directions
in a city and somebody says okay
you you know you say you're lost and
they say okay you're gonna go two blocks
down
you're gonna turn left and then you're
gonna see a landmark on your right and
then you're gonna go
um in the in the third door on your left
that's a lot of information at least for
me okay so the way you would
you would want to listen to that is
you're gonna go down the road
you know i see i already forgot you're
gonna take a le you're gonna go
left and you're just going to program
and instead of just hearing the word
left you're going to think the
l at the front of left and the t you're
going to
left okay and then so you're coding in
specific words and what this does is
this kind of hijacks these naturally
occurring attention mechanisms that the
auditory system likes to use
it's a little bit of data that for
auditory encoding
this kind of thing can be beneficial
there are a lot of data
that attention for auditory coding is
beneficial
there are a little bit of data showing
that deliberately encoding auditory
information
this way meaning trying to learn
auditory information this way
can be beneficial or can accelerate
learning and some of these features of
what i'm describing here
map onto some of these work that of mike
merzinick and others that have been
designed
to try and overcome things like stutter
and to treat various forms of auditory
learning disorders
but more importantly and perhaps more
powerful
is the work of mike merzinick that was
done with his
then graduate student greg reckenzone
that showed that
using the attentional system we can
actually learn much faster
and we can actually activate
neuroplasticity in the adult brain
something that's very challenging to do
and that the auditory system is one of
the main ways
in which we can access neuroplasticity
more broadly so i just want to take a
couple of minutes and describe the work
of reckon zone and merzinik because it's
absolutely
fantastic and fascinating what they did
is they had subjects try to learn
auditory information
except that they told them to pay
attention
to particular frequencies so now you
know what frequencies are so
essential essentially high-pitched
sounds or low-pitched sounds
what they found was just passively
listening to a bunch of stuff
does not allow the brain to change and
for that stuff to be remembered
at all that's not a surprise we've all
experienced the
you know the phenomena of having someone
talk and we see their mouth moving
like yeah this is really important
that's really important we're listening
we're trying to listen and then they
walk away and we think i didn't get
any of that and you wonder whether or
not it was them
maybe this is happening to you right now
may you wonder whether or not
it was you you wonder whether or not you
have trouble with learning or you have
attention deficit
it could be any number of different
things but what reckons own immersing
discovered was that if you
instruct subjects to listen for
particular cues within speech
or within sounds that not only can you
learn those things more quickly
but that you can remap these
tonatopic maps in the cortex that i
referred to earlier you actually get
changes in the neural architecture the
neural circuitry in the brain
and this can occur not only very rapidly
but they can occur in the adult brain
which prior to their work
was not thought to be amenable to change
it was
long thought that neuroplasticity could
only occur in the developing brain but
the work of reconcile
and merzenik in the auditory system
actually was some of the first
that really opened up everybody's eyes
and ears to the idea that the brain can
change in adulthood
so here's how this sort of process would
work and how you might apply it
if you are trying to learn music or
you're trying to learn
information that you're going to then
recite
you can decide to highlight certain
words
or certain frequencies of sound
or certain scales or certain keys on the
piano and to only focus on those for
certain learning bouts
okay so i'll give an example that's sort
of real time
for me meaning it's happening right now
i know generally what i want to say when
i arrive here
i even know specifically certain things
that i want to make sure get across to
you
but i don't think about every single
word that i'm going to say
and the precise order in which i'm going
to say those things
that would be actually very disruptive
because it wouldn't match my normal
patterns of speech and you'd probably
think
i was sounding rather robotic if i were
to do that
so one way that we can remember
information is as we write out for
instance something that we want to say
we can highlight particular words we can
underline those
if we're listening to somebody and
they are telling us information we can
decide just to highlight particular
words that they said to us and write
those down now of course we're listening
to all the information
but the work of reckon zone and merzinek
and
the work of others in addition them is
former student or former postdoc i don't
know which uh michael kilgard who's now
got his own lab down in texas or others
have shown that the cueing of attention
to particular features of speech
particular components of speech the way
in which it
increases our level of attention overall
allows us to capture more of the
information overall
and so i don't want this to be abstract
at all what this means is when you're
listening
you don't have to listen to every word
you're already listening to every word
all the information is coming in through
your ears
what you're trying to extract is
particular
things or themes within the content so
maybe you decide
if you're listening to me that you're
only going to listen to uh
the word tools or you're only going to
listen to when
my voice kind of goes above background
you get to decide what you
decide to listen to or not and what you
decide to focus on
isn't necessarily as important as the
fact that you're focusing
so i hope that's clear the auditory
system does this all the time with the
cocktail party effect what i'm talking
about is
exporting certain elements of the
mechanisms of the cocktail
party effect paying attention to the
onset and offset words
or particular notes within music or
particular scales
or you can make it even broader and
particular motifs
of music or particular sentences of
words or particular phrases
and in doing that you extract more of
the
information overall even though you're
not paying attention to all the
information
at once now i'd like to talk about a
phenomenon that you've all experienced
before
which is called doppler so the doppler
effect
is the way that we experience
sound when the thing that's making that
sound
is moving the simplest way to explain
this
is to translate the sound into the
visual world
once again so if you've ever seen a
a duck or a goose sitting in a pond or a
lake
and it's kind of bobbing up and down
what you'll notice is that the ripples
of water that extend out from that
duck or goose are fairly regularly
spaced in all directions
and that's because that ducker goose is
stationary it's moving up and down but
it's not moving forward or backward or
to the side
now if that duck or goose were to swim
forward by paddling its little
webbed feet under the surface you would
immediately notice
that the ripples of water that are close
to and in front of that duck or goose
would be closer together than the ones
that trailed it that were behind
and that is essentially what happens
with sound as well
with the doppler effect we experience
sounds that are closer to us
at higher frequency the ripples are
closer together
and sounds that are further away at
lower frequency
especially when they're moving past us
so if you've ever for instance
heard a siren in the distance
that's essentially my rendition of a
siren i don't know what ambulance or
police or what
passing you on a street that is the
doppler effect
the doppler effect is one of the main
ways that we
make out the direction that things are
arriving from
and their speeds and trajectories and we
get
very good from a very young age at
discerning what direction things are
arriving from and the direction
that they are going to pass us in
and the doppler effect has probably
saved your life many many times
in this way you just don't realize it
because you'll step off the curb or
you're
driving your car and you pull to the
side and so that the ambulance or fire
truck can go by
because you heard that siren
off in the distance and then you pull
away from the curb and you get back on
the road
in part because you don't see it any
longer but also you don't hear any other
sirens in the distance
now some animals such as bats are
exquisitely good and navigating their
environments according to sound
now we've all heard that bats don't see
that's actually not true they actually
have
vision but they just rely more heavily
on their auditory system
and the way that bats navigate in the
dark
and the way that bats navigate using
sound is through doppler
now they don't simply listen to whether
or not things
are coming at them or moving away from
them and pay attention to doppler like
the siren
example i gave for you what they do is
they generate
their own sounds so
a bat as it flies around is sending out
clicks i think that's my best bat sound
or maybe is
and they're clicking they're actually
propelling sound out at a particular
frequency
that they know now whether or not
they're conscious of it i don't know
i've never asked them and if i did ask
them i don't think they could answer and
if they could answer they couldn't
answer in a language that i could
understand
but the bat is essentially flying around
sending out
sound waves pinging its environment with
sound waves of a particular frequency
and then depending on the frequency of
sound waves that come back
they know if they're getting closer to
an object or further away from it so if
they send out
sounds at a frequency of this was much
slower than it would actually occur but
you know let's say one every half second
and it's coming back even faster then
they know they're getting closer
right because of the doppler effect and
if it comes back
more slowly they know that there's
nothing in front of them so
the bat is essentially navigating its
world by
creating these auras of sound
that bounce back onto them from the
various
objects trees etc buildings and people
it's kind of eerie to think about but
yes they
they see you with the experience you
with their sound they sense you
and they're using doppler to accomplish
it now i'd like to talk about
ringing in the ears this is something
that i get asked about a lot
and uh speaking of signal to noise i
don't know if i get
asked about it a lot because many people
suffer from ringing in their ears
or because the people who suffer from
ringing in their ears
suffer so much that they are more prone
to ask
so it could be a sampling bias i don't
know but i've been asked enough times
and some of the experiences of
discomfort that people have expressed
about having this ringing of the ears
really motivated me to go deep into this
literature
so the ringing of the ears that one
experiences
is called tinnitus not
tinnitus but tinnitus and tinnitus
can vary in intensity and it can vary
according to stress levels it can vary
across the lifespan or even time of day
so it's very subject to kind of
background effects and contextual
effects
so i think you know we all know that we
should do our best to maximize healthy
sleep we did a number of episodes on
that
essentially the first four episodes of
the huberman lab podcast we're all about
sleep and how to get better sleep
we all know that we should try and limit
our stress and we had an episode about
stress and ways to mitigate stress as
well
however there are people it seems that
are suffering from tinnitus for which
stress or lack of sleep just can't
explain the presence of the tinnitus
tinnitus can be caused by
disruption to these hair cells that we
talked about earlier or damage
to the hair cells so that's another
reason why even if you have good hearing
now that you want to protect that
hearing and really avoid
putting yourself into these kind of
two-hit environments environments where
there's a lot of background noise
and then you add another really loud
auditory stimulus this
also can happen at different times i
should mention if you go to a concert
where you listen to loud music with your
headphones and then you go to a concert
or you go into a very loud work
environment
the hair cells can still be vulnerable
and once those hair cells are
knocked out currently we don't have the
technology to put them back although
many groups including some excellent
groups at stanford
and elsewhere too of course are working
on ways to replenish those hair cells
and restore
hearing there are treatments for
tinnitus
that involve taking certain
substances there are medications
for tinnitus in the non-prescription
landscape which is typically what we
discuss
on this podcast when we discuss taking
anything
there are essentially four compounds for
which there are
quality peer-reviewed data where there
does not appear to be any
overt commercial bias meaning that
nothing's reported in the papers
as you know funding from a particular
company and those are melatonin
ginkgo bilboa zinc and magnesium
now i've talked about melatonin before
i'm personally not a fan
of melatonin as a sleep aid but
there are four studies first one
entitled the effects of melatonin
melatonin on tinnitus tinnitus excuse me
and sleep
second one treatment of central and
sensory neural tinnitus
with orally administered melatonin and
then the title goes on
much longer but it's a randomized study
i'm not going to read out all these
melatonin can it stop the ringing
which is an interesting article
double-blinded study
and the effects of melatonin on tinnitus
each one of these studies has anywhere
from 30 to
more than 100 subjects one case 102
subjects both genders
as they list them out typically uh it's
listed as sex not gender and studies so
it should say both
sexes but nonetheless um
an age range anywhere from 30 years old
all the way up to 65 plus i didn't see
any studies of people
younger than 30. all three
focused on melatonin not surprisingly
because of the titles
looking at a range of dosages anywhere
from three milligrams
per day which is sort of typical of many
supplements for melatonin
still much higher than one would
manufacture endogenously through your
own pineal gland
but three milligrams in these studies
for a duration of anywhere from 30 days
to
much longer in some cases six months and
all four of these studies found modest
yet still
statistically significant effects of
taking melatonin by mouth so it's orally
administered melatonin
in reducing the severity of
tinnitus so that's compelling at least
to me
i you know it doesn't sound like a cure
and of course
as always i'm not a physician i'm a
scientist so i don't prescribe anything
i only profess things i report to you
the science
you have to decide if melatonin is right
for you if you have
tinnitus and certainly i say that
both to protect myself but also protect
you you're responsible for your health
and well-being and
i'm not telling anyone to run out and
start taking melatonin for
tinnitus but it does seem that it can
have some effects
in reducing its symptoms
ginkgo boa is an interesting compound
it's
you know it's been prescribed for or
recommended for
many many things but
there are a few studies again
double-blinded studies lasting one to
six months
any one that has an impressive number of
subjects 978 subjects ranging from age
18 all the way up to 65. so on and so
forth
that show not
huge effects of ginkgo but
as they quote limited evidence suggests
that if tinnitus
is a side effect of something else in
particular
cognitive decline so age-related
tinnitus
might be helped by gingko bilboa
i won't go through all the details of
the zinc studies but it seems that zinc
supplementation at higher levels than
are typical
of most people's intakes of 50
milligrams per day do appear to be able
to reduce subjective symptoms of
tinnitus
in most of the people that took the
supplemented zinc there aren't a lot of
studies on that so i could only find one
double-blinded study it lasted anywhere
from one to six months 41 subjects both
genders listed out again here 45 to 64.
and they saw a decrease in the severity
of tinnitus
symptoms with 50 milligrams of elemental
zinc supplementation
and then last but not least is the
magnesium study
again only a single study it's a phase
two study
looking at a fairly limited number of
subjects so only 19 subjects
taking 532 milligrams of elemental
magnesium for those of you that take
magnesium there's magnesium and
elemental magnesium and it's always
translated on the
on the bottle but it was associated with
the lessening of symptoms
related to tinnitus so for you tinnitus
sufferers out there
you may already be aware of this you may
already be taking these things
uh and had no positive effects meaning
they didn't help
maybe not i hope that um you'll
at least consider these talk to your
doctor about them i do realize that
tinnitus is extremely disruptive
i can't say i empathize uh because i
don't from a place of experience that is
because i don't have tinnitus but
for those of you that don't including
myself you can imagine that hearing
sounds
of things that aren't there and the
ringing in one's ears can be very
disruptive and i think
um would be very disruptive and explains
why
people with tinnitus reach out so often
with questions about how to alleviate
that
and i hope this information was useful
to you i'd like to now talk about
balance and our sense of balance which
is controlled
by believe it or not our ears and
things in our ears as well as by our
brain
and elements of our spinal cord but
before i do that i want to ask you
another question or i would
rather i'd like to ask you to ask
yourself a question and answer it
which is how big are your ears
it turns out that the ears grow our
entire life
in the early stage of our life they grow
more slowly
and then as we age they grow more
quickly
you may have noticed if you have family
members
who are well into their 70s and 80s and
if you're fortunate and you're into
their 90s and maybe even hundreds
is that the ears of some of these
individuals get very very big
relative to their previous ear sizes
it turns out that biological age
can actually be measured according to
ear size
now you have to take a few measurements
but there's a believe it or not there is
a formula
in the scientific literature
if you know your ear circumference so
the distance
around your ear ears
plural presumably you have two most
people do
in millimeters so you're going to take
the circumference of your ears and
millimeters how would you do this
right how would you do this maybe you
take a string and you put it around your
ear
and then you measure the string that's
probably going to be easier than
marching around
your ear or somebody else's ear with a
ruler and measuring in millimeters so
what's your ear circumference
on the outside don't go in on the divot
or anything you're just going around as
if you're going to trace the
the closest fitting oval assuming your
ears are oval
closest fitting oval that matches your
ear circumference
take that number in millimeters subtract
from it
oh excuse me i should do this correctly
do that for both ears
add them together add those numbers
together divide by two get the average
for your two ears get your average ear
circumference and cross your two ears
then take that number in millimeters
subtract
88.1 and then whatever value that is
multiply it times 1.96 and that will
tell you
your biological age now why in the world
would this
be accurate but as we age
there are changes in number of different
biological pathways
one of those pathways is the pathways
related to collagen synthesis
so not only are our ears growing but
our noses are growing too my nose seems
to be growing
a lot but then again i did sports where
i would get my nose broken something i
don't recommend
so i always point out you don't get a
nose like mine doing yoga
but nonetheless my nose is still growing
and my ears are still growing and i
suspect as i get older
if i have the good fortune of living
into my 80s and 90s
my ears are going to continue to grow a
comparison between chronological age and
biological age is something that's of
really deep interest these days and the
work of
david sinclair at harvard medical school
and others
so-called horvath clocks that people
have developed
have tapped into how the epigenome in
the genome
can give us some insight into our
biological age and how that compares to
our chronological age most of us
know our chronological age because we
know when we were born
and we know where we are relative to
that now
but you can start to
make a little chart if you like about
your rates of ear growth your rates of
ear growth actually correlate pretty
well with your rates of
biological progression through this
thing that we call
life so it's not something that we think
about too often but
just like our dna and our epigenome and
some other markers
of metabolic health and hormone health
relate to our age
so does our collagen synthesis and one
of the places that shows up the most
is in these two little goodies on the
sides of our heads which are our ears
so even though it's a little bit of a
bizarre metric
it makes perfect sense in the biological
context so let's talk about balance
and how to get better at balancing the
reason why we're talking about balance
and how to get better at balancing
in the episode about hearing is that
all the goodies that are going to allow
you to do that are in your ears
they're also in your brain but they're
mostly in your ears
so as you recall from the beginning of
this episode you have two
cochlear cochleas that are one on each
side
of your head and that's a little spiral
snail shape thing that converts sound
waves
into electrical signals that the rest of
your brain can understand
right next to those you have what are
called semicircular canals
the semicircular canals can be best
visualized as thinking about
three hula hoops with marbles in them
so imagine that you have a hula hoop and
it's not
filled with marbles all the way around
it's just got some marbles down there at
the base
okay so if you were to move that hula
hoop around the marbles will move around
okay you've got three of those and each
one of those hula hoops has
these marbles that can move around one
of those hula hoops
is positioned vertically with respect to
gravity
so it's basically parallel to your nose
it sits like this if you're watching on
a video but basically it's upright
another one of those hula hoops is
basically at a 90 degree
angle to your nose it's basically
parallel to the floor if you're standing
up right now if you're seated
okay and the other one is kind of tilted
about 45 degrees in between those now
why is the system there well those
marbles within each one of those hula
hoops can move around
but they'll only move around if your
head moves in a particular way and there
are
three planes or three ways that your
head can move
your head can move up and down like i'm
nodding right now
so that's called pitch it's pitching
forward or pitching back
okay so it's a nod up and down
or i can shake my head no side to side
that's called yaw you pilots will be
very familiar with this
yaw not yawn yaw
and then there's roll tilting the head
from side to side
the way that a cute puppy might look at
you from side to side
okay or that if somebody doesn't really
understand or believe what you're saying
they might tilt their head very common
phenomena i mean nobody does that to me
but they they do that to each other
so pitchian roll
are the movements of the head in each of
the three major planes of motion as we
say
and each one of those causes those
marbles
to move in one or two of the various
hula hoops
okay so if i move my head up and down
when i nod
one of those hula hoops literally right
now the marbles are moving back and
forth they aren't actually
marbles by the way these are little um
little
kind of like little stones basically
little calcium
like deposits and when they roll back
and forth
they deflect little hairs little hair
cells that aren't like the hair cells
that we use for
measuring sound waves they're not too
different but they're not but they are
different
from them not like the hairs on our
heads but they're basically
rolling past these little hair cells and
causing them to deflect and when they
deflect downward
the neurons because hair cells are
neurons send
information up to the brain so if i move
my head like this
there's a physical movement of these
little stones in this
hula hoop as i'm referring to it but
they deflect these hairs
send those hairs which are neurons those
hair cells send information off to the
brain if i'm ahead from side to side
different little stones move if i roll
my head different stones move
this is an exquisite system that exists
in
all animals that have a jaw
so any fish that has a jaw has this
system
a puppy has this system any animal that
has a jaw has this
so-called balance system which we call
the vestibular system
one of the more important things to know
about the vestibular the balance system
is that it works together with the
visual system
let's say i hear something off to my
left and i swing my head over to the
left to see what it is
there are two sources of information
about where my head is relative to my
body and i need to know that
first of all when i quickly move my head
to the side
those little stones as i'm referring to
them i realize they're not actually
stoned but as
i'm referring to them they quickly
activate those
hair cells in that one semicircular
canal
and send a signal off to my brain that
my head just moved to the side like this
not that it went like this and pitched
back or not
that it tilted but it just moved to the
side but also
visual information slid past me my
my field of view i didn't have to think
about it but just slid past my field of
view
and when those two signals combine
my eyes then locked to a particular
location now
if this is at all complicated you can
actually uncouple
these things it's very easy to do you
can do this right now in fact i'd like
you to do this experiment if you're not
already doing something else that
requires your attention
and certainly don't do this if you're
driving okay you're going to sit down
and you're going to move your head to
the left very
slowly you're going with your eyes open
so you're going to move it very very
slowly
the whole thing should take about five
six maybe even 10 seconds to complete
okay i just did it now i'm going to do
it very quickly i'd like you to do it
very quickly as well
now do it slowly again
okay what you probably noticed is that
it's very uncomfortable to do it slowly
but you can do it very quickly without
much discomfort at all you just move
your head to the side
the reason is when you move your head
very slowly
those little stones at the base of that
hula hoop
they don't get enough momentum to move
so you're actually not
generating this signal to the brain that
your head is moving and what you'll
notice is that your eyes
have to go boom boom boom jumping over
step by step
whereas if you move your head really
quickly the signal gets off to your
brain and your eyes just go boom
right to the location you want to look
at so moving your body
slowly is actually very disruptive to
the
to the vestibular system and it's very
disruptive
to your visual system now if you've ever
had the misfortune of being on a boat
and you're going through big
oscillations on the boat for those of
you
sick folks that get sea sick this can
actually make certain people seasick
just to hear about it
that was big oscillations going up and
down and up and down
those are very disruptive we'll talk
about nausea in a minute and how to
offset that kind of nausea i get pretty
seasick but there are ways that you can
you can deal with this but this is
incredible because what it means it's a
purely physical system of these little
stones rolling around in there
and directing where your eyes should go
okay so you can do this
also just by looking up so let's just
say you're sitting in a chair you're
going to look up towards the ceiling
and your eyes will just go there you're
doing this eyes open you look down guys
now try doing it really really
slowly some people even get motion sick
doing this
which i if you do then just stop okay so
you can do this also to the side
although it works best if you're moving
your head from
from side to side um or
nodding up and down so what we're doing
here is we're uncoupling these two
mechanisms we're pulling them apart the
visual part and the vestibular part just
to illustrate to you
that normally these mechanisms in your
inner ear tell your eyes where to go
but as well your eyes tell your balance
system
your vestibular system how to function
so i'd like you to do a different
experiment
experiment i'm not going to do it right
now but basically stand up
if you get the opportunity you can do
this safely wherever you are you're
going to stand up
and you're going to look forward about
10 12 feet you can pick a point on a
wall or you can
um you know anywhere that you like if
you're out in public you know just do it
anyway you know just tell them you're
listening to
hubermann lab podcast and then someone's
telling you to do it
anyway if you don't want to do it don't
do it but basically do it stand on one
leg
and lift up the other leg you can bend
your knee if you like
and just look off into the distance
about 10 12 feet
if you can do that if you can stand on
one leg now close your eyes
chances are you're going to suddenly
feel what scientists call
postural sway you're going to start
swaying around a lot
it is very hard to balance with your
eyes closed
you might think well and if you think
about that it's like why is that that's
crazy
why would it be that it's hard to
balance with your eyes closed well
information about the visual world also
feeds back onto this vestibular system
so the vestibular system informs your
vision and tells you where to move your
eyes
and your eyes and their positioning tell
your balance system your vestibular
system
how it should function so there's a
really
cool way that you can learn to optimize
balance
you're not going to try and do this by
learning to balance with your eyes
closed
what you can do is you can raise one leg
and you can look at a short distance
maybe off to just the distance that your
thumb would be if you were to reach your
arm out in front of you although
you don't necessarily have to put your
thumb in front of you so maybe just
about two feet in front of you
then while still balancing you're going
to step your vision out
a further distance and then a further
distance and as far as you can possibly
see in the environment that you're in
and then you're going to march it back
to you now
what the literature shows is that this
kind of balance training where you
incorporate the visual system and
extending out and then marching back in
the point at which you direct your
visual focus
sends robust information about the
relationship between your visual world
and your balance system and of course
the balance system includes not just
these
these hula hoops the semicircular canals
but they communicate with the cerebellum
this so-called mini brain actually means
mini brain the back of your brain
combines that with visual information
and your map of the body surface
that pattern of training
is very beneficial for enhancing your
ability to balance because
the ability to balance is in part the
activation of
particular postural muscles but
just as much perhaps even more so it's
about being able to
adjust those postural muscles
muscles excuse me it's about the ability
to adjust those postural muscles
as you experience changes in your visual
world
and one of the most robust ways that you
can engage changes in your visual world
is through your own movement and so most
people are not trying to balance
in place right they're not just trying
to stand there like a statue on one leg
most of what we think about when we
think about balance is for sake of sport
or dynamic balance of being able to
break ourselves and
um when we're lunging in one particular
direction to stop ourselves that is
and then to move in another direction or
for skateboarding or surfing or
cycling or any number of different
things gymnastics so the visual system
is the primary input by which you
develop balance but you can't do it just
with the visual system
so what i'm recommending is if you're
interested in cultivating a sense of
balance understand the relationship
between these semicircular canals
understand that they are both driving
eye movements and they are driven by eye
movements it's a reciprocal relationship
and then even just two or three minutes
a day
or every once in a while even three
times a week
maybe five minutes maybe 10 minutes you
pick
but if you want to enhance balance you
have to combine
changes in your visual environment with
a static posture standing on one leg
and shifting your visual environment or
static visual view
looking at one thing and changing your
body posture
okay so those two things we now know
from the scientific literature
combine in order to give an enhanced
sense of balance and there's a really
nice paper
that was published in 2015 called
effects of balance training on balance
performance
this was in healthy adults it's a
systematic review and a meta-analysis a
meta-analysis is when you combine a lot
of literature from a lot of different
papers
and extract the really robust and the
less robust statistical
effects so it's a really nice paper as
well
there are some papers out there uh for
instance uh comparison of static balance
and the role of vision
in the elite athletes this is um
essentially the paper that i've
extracted most of the information
that i just gave you from and that paper
and there are some others as well um but
basically i distilled them down into
their core components the core
components are
move your vision around while staying
static still but in a balanced position
like standing on one leg
could be something more complicated if
you're somebody who can do more
complicated movements
unilateral movements seem to be
important so
standing on one leg as opposed to both
right or
trying to generate some tilt is another
way to go about it or
imbalance meaning one limb
asymmetrically being activated compared
to the other limb
and then the other way to encourage or
to cultivate
and build up this vestibular system and
your sense of balance
actually involves movement itself
acceleration
so that's what we're going to talk about
now so up until now i've been talking
about balance only in the static sense
like standing on one leg for instance
but
that's a very artificial situation even
though you can train balance that way
most people who want to enhance their
sense of balance for sport or dance or
some other endeavor
want to engage balance in a dynamic way
meaning moving through lots of different
planes of movement
maybe even sometimes while squatting
down low or
jumping and landing or making
trajectories that are different angles
for that we need to consider that the
vestibular system
also cares about acceleration so it
cares about head position it cares about
eye position and where the eyes are and
where you're looking
but it also cares about what direction
you're moving and how fast
and one of the best things that you can
do to enhance your sense of balance
is to start to bring together your
visual system
the semicircular canals of the inner ear
and
what we call linear acceleration so if i
move forward in space rigidly upright
it's a vastly different situation than
if i'm leaning to the to the side
one of the best ways to cultivate a
better sense of balance literally
within the sense organs and the neurons
and the
biology of the brain is to
get into modes where we are accelerating
forward
typically it's forward while also tilted
with respect to gravity now this would
be the carve
on a skateboard or on a surfboard or a
snowboard
this would be the taking a corner on a
bike
while being able to lean safely of
course lean
into the turn so that your head is
actually tilted
with respect to the earth so anytime
that we are rigidly upright we aren't
really
exercising the vestibular system
imbalance
this is why you know you see people in
the gym on these um one of those bouncy
balls
bocce ball bouncy ball is the one that
the guys roll in the park right bouncy
balls where they're bouncing back and
forth
that will work the small stabilizing
muscles but what i'm talking about is
getting into modes where you actually
tilt the body and the head with respect
to earth what i mean is with respect to
earth's gravitational pull
now the cerebellum is a very interesting
structure because
not only is it involved in balance but
it's also involved in
skill learning and in generating timing
of movements
it's a fascinating structure deserving
of an entire episode or several episodes
all on its own but some of the outputs
of the cerebellum
meaning the neurons in the cell
cerebellum get inputs but they also
send information out the outputs of the
cerebellum
are strongly linked to areas of the
brain that release
neuromodulators that make us feel really
good in particular serotonin and
dopamine and this is an
early emerging subfield within
neuroscience but a lot of what are
called the
non-motor outputs of the cerebellum
have a profound influence not just on
our ability to
learn how to balance better but also
how we feel overall so for you
exercisers out there
i do hope people are getting regular
healthy amounts of exercise we've talked
about what that means
in previous episodes so at least 150
minutes a week of endurance work
some strength training a minimum of five
sets per body part to maintain
musculature even if you don't want to
grow muscles you want to do that in
order to maintain healthy
strength and bones etc if you're doing
that but you're only
doing things like curls in the gym
squats in the gym riding the peloton
or even if you're outside running and
you're getting forward acceleration
but you're never actually getting tilted
right you're never actually getting
tilted with respect to earth's
gravitational pull
you're not really exercising and
getting the most out of your nervous
system activation of the
of the cerebellum in this way of being
tilted or the head being tilted in the
body being tilted while in acceleration
typically forward acceleration
but sometimes side to side has a
profound
and positive effect on our sense of mood
and well-being
and as i talked about in a previous
episode it can also enhance our ability
to
learn information in the period after
generating those tilts and that
acceleration
and that's because the cerebellum has
these outputs to these areas of the
brain that release these neuromodulators
like serotonin
and dopamine and they make us feel
really good
i think this is one of the reasons why
growing up i had some friends
some of whom might have been you know
the world heavyweight champions of
laziness
for essentially everything except they
would wake up at 4
30 in the morning to go surf they would
like drive
they would get up so early to go surf i
al it's not just surfers um and some
surfers by the way i should point out
are
not lazy humans they do a lot of other
things but i knew people that couldn't
be motivated to do anything
but they were highly driven to get into
these experiences
of forward acceleration while tilted
with respect to gravity
likewise with snowboarding or skiing or
cycling those modes of exercise
seem to have an outsized effect both on
our well-being
and our ability to translate the
vestibular
balance that we achieve in those
endeavors to our ability to balance
while doing other things so and i don't
mean psychological balance necessarily i
mean
physical balance so for those of you
that don't think of yourselves as
very coordinated or with very good
balance
getting into these modes of acceleration
forward movement or lateral movement
while getting
tilted even if you have to do it slowly
it could be beneficial i do believe
and the scientific literature points the
fact that it will be beneficial
for cultivating better sense of physical
balance
it can really build up the circuits of
this vestibular system
and then of course the feel-good
components of
acceleration while tilted or while
getting the head into different
orientations relative
to gravity well that's the explanation
for roller coasters
some people hate roller coasters they
make them feel nauseous
many people love roller coasters and one
of the reasons they love roller coasters
is because of the way that
when you get the body even if you're not
generating the movement you get the body
into forward acceleration and you're
going upside down and tilted to the side
as the tracks go from side to side and
tilt etc you're getting activation of
these deeper
brain nuclei that trigger the release of
neuromodulators that just make us feel
really really good in fact some people
get a long arc a long duration kind of
buzz
from having gone through those
experiences some people who hate roller
coasters
are probably getting nauseous just
hearing about that
so i encourage people to get into modes
of acceleration while tilted every once
in a while provided you can do it safely
it's an immensely powerful way to build
up
your skills in the realm of balance and
it's
also for most people very very pleasing
it feels really good because of the
chemical relationship between forward
acceleration
and head tilt and body tilt now speaking
of
feeling nauseous some people suffer from
vertigo
some people feel dizzy some people get
lightheaded
an important question to ask yourself
always if you're feeling
quote unquote dizzy or lightheaded is
are you dizzy
or are you lightheaded now we're not
going to diagnose anything here because
there's just no way we can do that this
is essentially me shouting into a tunnel
so we don't know what's going on
with each and every one of you but if
ever you feel that your world
is spinning but that you can focus
on your thumb for instance but the rest
of the world is
spinning and your thumb is stationary
that's called being dizzy
now if you feel like you're falling or
that you feel like you need to get
down onto the ground because you feel
light-headed
that's being lightheaded and often times
with language we don't distinguish
between being dizzy and being
light-headed
now there are a lot of ways that
dizziness and lightheadedness can
occur and i don't even want to begin to
guess at the number of different
things and ways that it could happen for
those of you that suffer from it because
it could be
any number of them but oftentimes if
people are light-headed
yes it could be low blood sugar it could
also be that you're dehydrated
it could also be that you are low in
electrolytes we talked about this in a
previous
episode but we will talk about it more
in a future episode
many people have too little sodium in
their system
salt and that's why they feel
light-headed
i have family members who for years
thought they had disrupted blood sugar
they would get shaky jittery lightheaded
feel like they were nauseous etc and
simply the addition of a little sea salt
to their water remedied the problem
entirely i don't
think it's going to remedy every issue
of lightheadedness out there by any
stretch
but just the addition of salt in this
particular case help the person and
they are not alone many people who think
that they have low blood sugar actually
are light-headed because of low
electrolytes and because of the way that
salt carries
water into the system and creates
changes in blood volume etc
low sodium can often be a source of
light-headedness
as can low blood sugar and of course
other things as well now for dizziness
or seasickness we were all taught that
you need to pick a point on the horizon
and focus on it but actually
that's not correct it is true that if
you are
down in the cabin of a boat or you're on
the lower deck
and all you can see are things up close
to you
that getting sloshed around like so or
the boat going up and down
like so i think i'm getting a little
seasick even as i do this and i describe
it
focusing on things close to you can be
problematic and in that case the advice
to go up on deck
and get fresh air and to look off into
the horizon that part is correct
but focusing your eyes on a particular
location on the horizon
is effectively like trying to move very
slowly as i had you do before where
you're trying to move your head very
slowly while
fixating on one location your eyes and
your balance system were designed to
move together
so really what you want to do is allow
your visual system to track
with your vis your vestibular system
this is why
sitting in the back of an uber or a taxi
and being on your
phone can make you suddenly feel very
nauseous
sometimes the cabs particularly in new
york city they have a lot of occluders
they have a lot of stuff blocking your
field of view there's usually a little
portal
out there where you can see out to the
front of the of the uh of the front
windshield but there's all this stuff
now televisions in the back seat and
you're watching that television and the
cab is moving
you're in linear acceleration and
sometimes you're taking corners you're
breaking so then your
your vestibular system has to adjust to
that if you're looking at your phone
or a book or even if you're talking to
somebody
actually i'm starting to feel a little
nauseous i'm gonna i promise i'm not
gonna finish this episode by vomiting at
the end
at least not here but what you what can
happen
is that you're uncoupling your v the
visual information
from your motion from your vestibular
information
you want those to be coupled this is why
a lot of people have to drive
they can't be in the passenger seat
because when you drive you also get
what's called proprioceptive feedback
your body is sending signals also to the
vestibular system about where you are in
space
when you're the passenger you're just
getting jolted around
as the person is driving and if you're
looking at your phone it's even worse
and if you're looking at the
occluder between you and the two front
seats
that's even worse so this is why staring
out the front windshield is great but
you don't want to fixate
okay so hopefully i um spared a few
people and hopefully a few
cab drivers of having people get sick in
their cars or ubers
let your visual system and your
vestibular system work together
if appropriate get into linear
acceleration
and you'll improve your sense of balance
once again we've covered a tremendous
amount of information
now you know how you hear how you make
sense of the sounds in your environment
how those come into your ears and how
your brain processes them
in addition we talked about things like
low-level white noise and even binaural
beats
which can be used to enhance certain
brain states certain rhythms within the
brain and even dopamine release
in ways that allow you to learn better
and we talked about the balance system
and this incredible relationship
between your vestibular apparatus
meaning
the portions of your inner ear that are
responsible for balance and your
visual system and gravity and you can
use those
to enhance your learning as well as well
as just to enhance
your sense of balance if you're learning
from this podcast
please subscribe on youtube that really
helps us in addition
please leave us any comments or feedback
or suggestions for future episode
content
on youtube in the comment section if you
haven't already subscribed on apple and
spotify please do that as well
and on apple you have the opportunity to
leave us up to a five star review
at apple you can also leave us comments
and feedback
during this episode i mentioned some
supplements we partnered with thorn
because thorn has the very highest
levels of stringency with respect to the
quality of their ingredients
and accuracy about the amounts of those
ingredients contained within their
products
if you'd like to see the products that i
take from thorn you can go to
t-h-o-r-n-e dot com slash the letter u
huberman so that's thorne dot com slash
u
slash huberman to see all the
supplements that i take and if you do
that you can get twenty percent off
any of those supplements or 20 off any
of the supplements that thorn makes
for those of you that might want to
support us in other ways we have a
patreon account it's patreon.com
andrewhuberman and there you can support
our podcast
at any level that you like in addition
if you'd like to support the podcast
please check out our sponsors mentioned
at the beginning of the episode that is
absolutely the best way to support us
last but not least i'd like to thank you
for your time and attention
and desire and willingness to learn
about vision and balance
and of course thank you for your
interest in science